HEARING OF ITS COMMITTEE ON
RATHER RAVAN TEN DUE TO THE
BAND WE ARE TO PRACTICE
PHYSICAL DISTANCING HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM AND THROUGHOUT THE
CAPITOL BUILDING SO WE'RE ONLY
ABLE TO HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER
OF PEOPLE WATCH AND PARTICIPATE
IN THE HEARING IN PERSON WE ARE
ALSO REQUIRED THAT WE'RE HIRING
THAT MASCOT MORNING PHYSICAL
DISTANCING BE MAINTAINED BY ALL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TESTIFYING WEATHER HERE IN THE
ROOM ARE AT A VIDEO
CONFERENCING SITE. IF YOU DO
NOT HAVE A MASK WE CAN PROVIDE
ONE FOR YOU IN A FEW DIFFERENT
OPTIONS FOR WITNESSES TESTIMONY
TODAY OF ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC HERE IN THE ROOM WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY ON A BILL
PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND AND I
WILL ASK YOU TO APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME I WOULD ASK THE PUBLIC NOT
TOUCH THE MICROPHONE. YOU CAN
EXIT THE HEARING ROOM ONCE
YOU'RE DONE TESTIFYING A RETURN
TO YOUR SEAT PLEASE BE SURE TO
OBSERVE PHYSICAL DISTANCE
SAMPAI LEAVING THE HEARING ROOM
INCLUDING LIMITING ELEVATOR.
USED TO ONE PERSON AT A TIME.
FOR DIAL WITNESSES WE WILL ALL
BE USING A MODERATED TELEPHONE
SERVICE THROUGH WHICH ANY
WITNESS CAN TESTIFY ON A BILL.
THE CALLING NUMBER FOR THIS
HEARING IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN.
SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN AND THE ACCESS CODE S.
ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR TWO
ZERO TWO. YOU CAN ALSO FIND
THIS NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY
REVENUE AND TAXATION COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON YOUR TV
SCREEN IF YOU ARE CALLING IN
PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE AS WE ONLY HAVE THREE
BILLS. ON TODAY'S AGENDA. IF
YOU'RE CALLING IN PLEASE
ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND NOISE
INCLUDES MEETING HER LIVESTREAM
BROADCAST AND YOUR SMART
DEVICES TO REDUCE THE SOUND
DISTORTION. IF YOU ARE HAVING
ANY PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATE
OF PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN CALL
THE COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE SIX
AND THREE ONE NINE TWO ZERO
NINE EIGHT AND MY STAFF WILL BE
THERE TO HELP YOU I ALSO WANT
TO NOTE THAT WE ARE ACCEPTING
WRITTEN TESTIMONY TO THE
POSITION LETTER PORTAL ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. NOW I LIKE
TO GO OVER A FEW ADDITIONAL
HOUSEKEEPING ANNOUNCEMENTS. FOR
THE BILLS BEING TAKEN UP TODAY
WILL TAKE NO MORE THAN TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
AND TO PROMOTE WITNESSES
OPPOSITION. OR WITH CONCERNS.
THESE WITNESSES WILL HAVE TWO
MINUTES EACH TO PROVIDE THEIR
TESTIMONY ALL SUBSEQUENT
WITNESSES SHOULD STATE THEIR
NAME THEIR ORGANIZATION AND
THEIR POSITION ON THE BILL
ONLY. FINALLY I WOULD LIKE TO
WELCOME OUR NEW VICE CHAIR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WIN WHO'S NOT
HERE RIGHT NOW BUT WELCOME.
WELL AS ARE OTHER NEW MEMBERS
OF THE SUMMER BRAZEN AND
SCIARRETTO. AND WELCOME BACK MR
MAYES. PLEASE BUT CHAD MAYES IS
STILL HERE. IT KEITH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER REVISTAS ARE ABOUT.
KOOREMAN ADOPTION OF GIVE ME
RULES IT LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE A
QUORUM MISTER UP PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. BURKE WHEN GREAT
GRAYSON THERE LEVINE- NAMES.
MULLIN PETRIE-NORRIS. QUIRK
HERE THREE OF US C. R. TO THEIR.
YOU HAVE A CAR CREATE A
CORNICES DEVILISH WITHOUT WILL
MOVE ON TO OUR FIRST AND OUR
GENDER THE DOBSON OF PROPOSE
COMMITTEE RULES FOR THE TWENTY
AND TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
LEGISLATIVE SESSION THESE RULES
WORK PREVIOUSLY DISTRIBUTED
EACH COMMITTEE MEMBERS OPPOSITE
APPROVED BY THE CHIEF CLERK.
NAME THEY ARE LARGELY THE SAME
AS THE RULES ADOPTED FOR LAST
SESSION I THINK WE HAVE A
MOTION MOVE THE RULES WE HAVE A
SECOND- MR OF PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. BURKE HI WHEN I GREAT. I
GRAYSON ALL RIGHT LET ME. MAYES
ALL RIGHT MULLIN PETRIE-NORRIS
I WORK HI. THIS RIVAS. THEY ARE
TO HI. IT TURNED US CREATE THE
MINERALS HAVE BEEN ADOPTED
THANK YOU ALL MOVING THE FILE
ITEM. EIGHTY FOUR SIXTY SIX.
KITCHENER'S YOU LIKE TO START.
YEAH YOU CAN'T NOT. THANK YOU
MATT CHAIR. THANK I RIPLEY I'M
HERE USING ASK FOR YOUR OF AB
FOUR SIX SIX WHAT THAT WERE
HELP UNITE MORE CALIFORNIANS
WITH THEIR AND CLAIM TO
PROPERTY I DO HAVE A COUPLE OF
SUPPORTERS HERE TO TESTIFY OR
PERHAPS ON THE YES WE HAVE TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT I
GOT THEN ADD FOR FO THE
ASSISTANT DEPUTY CONTROLLER OF
LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS THE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE. AND AND
THAT CAN SEE THAT LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR AT THE FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD- IF WE COULD PLEASE GET
IN SOME MONARCH BRIEF COMMENTS
FROM OUR WITNESSES THAT WOULD
BE. GREAT IF WE COULD AS A
MODERATOR TO CONNECT US FIRST
WITH BEN TREE FULL OF THE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE. MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY TODAY
I'LL KEEP THIS BRIEF- MANY
VENTURE ABOUT YUP THE
CONTROLLER BETTY- WITH ME ON
THE LINE AS WELL JULIA MIKE
MORRELL CLEAN PROPERTY
DIVISION. BECAUSE ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS- BEFORE YOU PLEASED
TO SUPPORT THE THIRTY SIX ITEM
NUMBER ONE MAN. ARTS WHICH THE
FOR TAX BOARD TO SHARE WITH THE
CORPORATE RETURN OF.
CONTROLLERS SUPPORTING UPPER
KING AWARENESS IMPROVE COLDER
COMPLIANCE THE OAKLAND LOSS.
CONTACT YOUR MINISTER THE
IMPRINT PRO WHICH STATE CARDS
COUNTY PROPER AND PROVIDE THE
MEANS TRYING. TO ITS RIGHTFUL
OWNER. ARE CURRENTLY AND THAT A
WHOLE OF CRY- TO REPORT REMIT
UNCLAIMED FOR TO THE- ARE WHEN
BEEN ACTIVITY OR CALL. WITH THE
OWNER FOR A PERIOD- THIS OFFICE
AT. THAT LESS THAN TWO PER OF
THE DURING. WITH THE L.
PROPERTY. AT THE- THAT OUT OF
COMPLIANCE BE HOLDING THEM IN
EXCESS OF SEVENTEEN BILLION
DOLLARS. IN UNCLAIMED PROPERTY.
IN TWENTY NINETEEN THE BY ACT
REQUIRED THE ORDER. ALLEGED OPS
TWO AND UNCLAIMED PROPERTY
BEFORE. BY THE LAW.
ADDITIONALLY THE BUDGET
REQUIRED PROJECT BOARD. THAT
ABOUT QUITE ON THE HAPPENS TAX.
DONE AFTER TO INCREASE HOLCOMB.
THIS BILL PROVIDES THE PLAN TAX
ABILITY TO SHARE THE DATA WITH-
COLLECTED BY. QUITE THE BILL
AND BOOST RETURN I THINK YOU
AND FOR HOW TO ANSWER ANY. YOU
HAVE. THANK THANK YOU MR FIVE
ITEMS AND WE'LL HEAR FROM MS
KING. YES YOU THAT AFTER MADAM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
THE NEXT MOVE AND I THE LEAD
TO. FOR THE FRENCH TAX BOARD
FIRST I WANT TO SINCERELY THANK
MEMBER NORRIS OR CARE THE- AND
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR HEARING
TODAY. I KNEW HER SOME
BACKGROUND ON THE TOPIC BUT I
JUST WANTED TO BE AT THAT AFTER
WORKED JUNK WITH THE- STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE- S. TO
IDENTIFY QUESTION. TO INCLUDE
ON THE BUSINESS AND OF WHICH-
IN ORDER TO HELP THE WITH THEIR
PROGRAM AND WHAT'S WITH OUR
ACTUALLY. ON QUITE PROPERTY
PROBE. AB T. V. SUBMITTED A
REPORT EMERGED TO THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET COMMITTEE
AND ALSO- BUT HOWEVER IN ORDER
TO BE ABLE TO SHARE SME OF THE
INFORMATION. THAT I GATHERED
FROM THE COOK QUESTION YOU'RE
PROPOSING TO BE ADDED TO THE
RETURNED. DATA SHARING
AUTHORITY IS NEEDED. AND AFTER
B. CURRENTLY HAS THE AUTHORITY
UNDER- REVENUE TAXATION CODE
ONE NINE FIVE FIVE FOUR TO
SHARE SPECIFIED INFORMATION
WITH THE CONTROLLER. HOWEVER
THE SPECIFIC INFORMATION
DOESN'T INCLUDE THAT RESPONSE
TO THE QUESTIONS. THAT ARE
BEING ADDED SO THIS BILL WOULD
EXPAND THAT AUTHORITY. AND HAVE
TO THE SPONSOR OF THE BILL
WHICH WAS DEVELOPED IN
COLLABORATION WITH SCO AND OUR
THREE MEMBER BOARD SUPPORTED
TO. VOTED TO SUPPORT THE BILL
AND LAST DECEMBER. AND OUT
WITHOUT. LEADS WE WILL NOT BE
ABLE TO SHARE THE INFORMATION.
WITH REGARDS TO THE NEW BUT
QUESTIONS. AND ALSO- EFFORTS
WOULD EASILY. THIS THE CHAIN
ARE PART OF OUR NORMAL OF AND
WE DO INTO THE ANY. COSTS THANK
YOU FOR TIME AND I'M ALSO HOW
TO ANSWER COST. THANK YOU THE
MODERATOR WOULD NOW PLEASE OPEN
THE MAY FOR A ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN. ZERO
THAT COMMAND AGAIN ONE THEN.
ZERO AND MADAM CHAIR WE HAVE NO
COMMENT AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
IS THERE ANYONE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT VIA REMOTE
VIDEO STATION AT THIS TIME.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE HEARING ROOM- NO I WITH THE
MODERATOR PLEASE NOT OPEN THE
MAINLAND FOR ANY OPPOSITION
TESTIMONY. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO CHECK COMMAND AGAIN
AND. ONE ZERO. AND MADAM CHAIR
WE HAVE NO COMMENT THAT THAT'S
GREAT IS THERE ANYONE WISHING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION BE
REMOTE VIDEO STATION AT THIS
TIME SEEING NONE IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE ROOM WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION- SO
SEEING THAT ONES IN THE ROOM
BUT ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON-
QUESTIONS COMING FROM THE
COMMITTEE. BUT THE- THING WE
I'M SORRY MEMBER WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND THANK YOU TO AS THE S. U.
S. OFFICE AND THE FTP FOR YOUR
EFFORTS TO CONNECT MORE
CALIFORNIANS WITH UNCLAIMED
PROPERTY- WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NINTH. WE
HAD A MOTION AND A SECOND ARE
RAINY. MR OF WHICH LIKE
COLORADO. THE MOTION IS THE
PASTOR PREPARATIONS BURKE I.
BURKE HI WHEN I GREAT. GRAYSON
ALL RIGHT GRAYSON HI LEVINE THE
CONVENE I MAYES RIGHT MAYES I
MULLIN. MULLIN ABSENT
PETRIE-NORRIS I HM OR SI OF
COURSE I WORK HI- THREE OF US.
THREE OF US HI SAY ARE TO HIGH
THEY ARE T<c.cyan>. THE BILL HAS</c>
NINE VOTES. THE OTHER SIDE PART
OF A CLASS LIVING FILE ITEM TWO
EIGHTY SEVEN FORTY TWO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CALDERON YOU ARE WELCOME
TO BEGIN. ONE OF THE BILL
SECOND. GIVE A BRIEF. OKAY
EIGHTY SEVEN FORTY TWO
EXTENSIVE CRITICAL FUNDING
SOURCE FOR HOMELESS STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA PREVIOUS LEGISLATION
ESTABLISHED THE SCHOOL SUPPLIES
FOR HOMELESS CHILDREN FUND TO
PROVIDE SCHOOL SUPPLIES AND
HEALTH RELATED PRODUCTS TO
HOMELESS CHILDREN THROUGH
TAXPAYERS VOLUNTARY
CONTRIBUTIONS. THE FUND IS SET
TO EXPIRE IN BY TWENTY TWENTY
TWO AT A TIME WHEN WE WILL NEED
TO SUPPORT THE STUDENTS THE
MOST. WITH ME IN SUPPORT OF AB
SEVEN FORTY TWO OUR MELISSA SH
GOOD MAKER AND THE NEEDED
BENITO DELGADO OLSON OF SUPPLY
BANK .ORG. THANK YOU- MODERATOR
IF YOU COULD PLEASE CONNECT US
WITH BENITO DUGOUT OLSON OF THE
SUPPLY BANK. WE HAVE BEEN NEED
A ON THE LINE THANK YOU. OKAY
THANK YOU- GOOD AFTERNOON THANK
YOU CHAIRPERSON BURKE AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AND
ONCE AGAIN TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CALDERON FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP.
ON THIS IMPORTANT PROGRAM FOR A
STATE HOMELESS CHILDREN I'LL
TRY TO BE INCREDIBLY BRIEF IS
THAT NOW WE JUST HAVE TWO
MINUTES- MY NAME IS BENITO GOT
OLSON AND I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE NONPROFIT
SUPPLY BANK DOT ORG WHICH
PROVIDES ESSENTIAL BASIC NEEDS
MATERIAL. TO VULNERABLE PEOPLE
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE AND
ADMINISTERS THE SCHOOL SUPPLIES
FOR HOMELESS CHILDREN FUND
PROGRAM FOR TEN YEARS THIS
PROGRAM HAS PROVIDED MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS OF SCHOOL SUPPLIES
AND HEALTH RELATED SUPPLIES TO
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
HOMELESS CHILDREN YOUTH. AND
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AS WELL AS
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SHELTERS
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE WE KNOW
FROM OUR SCHOOL SITE SPECIFIC
ANALYSIS OF HOMELESS STUDENT
IDENTIFICATION THAT THERE IS
SIMPLY NO COMMUNITY OR
LEGISLATIVE DISTRICT IN
CALIFORNIA THE DOES NOT HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF HOMELESS
STUDENTS IDENTIFIED EACH YEAR.
ENSURING EQUITABLE DISTRIBUTION
OF SUPPLIES THIS PROGRAM
PARTNERS WITH MORE THAN THREE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY COUNTY OFFICE
OF EDUCATION SCHOOL DISTRICTS
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SHELTERS AND
HOMELESS LIAISON THEY EMPLOYED
HIM THROUGH THE STUDENTS MOST
IN NEED ARE THE ONES REACHED.
THE SIDE NOTE THIS NETWORK OF
PARTNERSHIPS IN SIMILAR
NETWORKS APPLY THINK THAT'LL
WORK HAS FOR OTHER PROGRAMS
HAVE COLLECTIVELY BEEN
INSTRUMENTAL IN OUR ONGOING
COPING NINETEEN EMERGENCY
SUPPLIES PROGRAM WHICH
CONTINUES TO OPERATE IN
MULTIPLE LOCATIONS IN ALL
COUNTIES THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
WITH YOUR SUPPORT WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING THIS WORK
FOR THE FALL BACK TO SCHOOL
SEASON WITH OUR AGENCY PARTNERS
FRONTLINE WORKERS IN THE
COMMUNITY AND CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH THE GOOD PEOPLE THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR TIME
TODAY AND AGAIN TO THE FAMILY
MEMBER FOR A LEADERSHIP. AND
WE'RE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU- MODERATOR
YOU COULD PLAY. OPEN FOR MILLER
IT MARK. IN MANILA SHE MIGHT
LINE ITSELF. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIRMAN MY
NAME IS SIX CAN MAKE AND
PROJECT- FOR K. WELFARE AND
ATTENDANCE AT THE COUNTY
DEVELOPMENTAL COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION THAT PROBABLY SERVED
AS THE VICE CHAIR OF THE BOARD
FOR SUPPLY THANK FOR THE PAST
TWO YEARS I'VE HAD THE
PRIVILEGE OF SERVING INSTANCE
SUPPORT SERVICES FOR THE PAST
TWENTY FIVE YEARS BOTH WITH A
VERY LARGE DISTRICT AND THE
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION.
FOURTEEN OF THOSE YEARS OF THE
HOMELESS GREEN MOUNTAIN
CALIFORNIA HAS IDENTIFIED OVER
TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY THOUSAND
STUDENTS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS AND EVERY LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES ACROSS THE
STATE IS CHARGED BY FEDERAL
ENCAMPMENTS STATE MANDATE TO
APPOINT A HOMELESS LIAISON WHO
IS EXPECTED TO IDENTIFY AND
ADDRESS THE EDUCATIONAL NEEDS
OF THE STUDENTS. THIS COULD BE
SCHOOL SUPPLIES BACKPACKS
CALCULATORS HYGIENE ITEMS ALONG
WITH THE RESOURCES FOR
TRANSPORTATION COUNSELING
MEDICAL AND MORE I CAN SPEAK AS
A FORMER LIAISON THAT THERE IS
NOT ENOUGH DIFFICULT QUITE FAR
SCHOOL DISTRICT TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE. THE NEEDED RESOURCES.
I CAN'T OF THE VICE CHAIR THE
BOARD THAT THREE DAY TEENAGE
MODEL THE- HAS BEEN A TO ENABLE
THEM. THREE TO PROVIDE HUNDRED
AND OF BACK. WILL SUPPLIES
HYGIENE ITEMS. UP AND DOWN THE
STATE. THIS TYPE OF PARTNERS IN
THE- TO HELP. STRETCH THEM FOR
SOURCES FOR THERE JUST STATE
EXTRA HOME. IDIOTS WILL EVER
DAY IN OR ONLINE READY TO LEARN.
ONE DAY AT WORK I GAVE US
GRADER AND NEW BACK. FILLED
WITH SUPPLIES SHE CAME UP TO ME
WITH THE BIGGEST SMILE EVER AND
ASKED IF YOU COULD GIVE ME A
HUG. HE TOLD ME THAT THIS WAS
HER BEST DAY EVER. I'M THINKING
IT'S JUST A BACKPACK BUT TO
HER. IT WAS SO MUCH MORE. I
URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR EIGHTY
SEVEN FORTY JAIL WHICH LOOKS
SENATE PROVISIONS CURRENTLY IN
PLACE FOR THE SCHOOL SUPPLIES.
FOR HOMELESS CHILDREN CHILDREN
VOLUNTARY TAX CONTRIBUTION PLAN
SO WE CAN CONTINUE TO MEET THE
OVERWHELMING NEED THAT THAT
OFTEN UNDERSERVED OVERLOOKED
POPULATION. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY AND
I'M OF THE L. AVAILABLE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU OF THE MODERATOR NOW
PLEASE THE MAIN FOR ANY. TO IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
FOR COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF AB
SEVEN FORTY TWO PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. THAT COMMAND
AGAIN. ONE NINE ZERO. AND
MEDICARE ACTUALLY WE HAVE WE
HAVE A COMMENT FROM LINE
NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
CALIFORNIA LIFE JOHN FAMILY
SERVICES IN SUPPORT. MADAM
CHAIR THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENT AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT
IS THERE ANYONE WISHING SAYS
FIND SUPPORT VIA REMOTE VIDEO.
STEAM NINE IS THERE ANYONE AND-
THEN HEARING ROOM NOPE SEEING
NONE. WITH THE MODERATOR PLEASE
OPEN THE MAIN OUTLINE NOW FOR
ANY OPPOSITION TESTIMONY. FOUR
COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION TO AB
SEVEN FORTY TWO PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. THAT COMMAND
AGAIN ONE THEN. ZERO AND MADAM
CHAIR THERE ARE NO COMMENTS AT
THE TIME. ALL RIGHT IS THERE
ANYONE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
IN THE REMOTE VIDEO NO IN THAT
CHAMBER KNOWN- ANY COMMENTS
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE AS SOMEONE ARE
CALLED OR WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE I AGREE WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND MISTER
ROUGHLY CULTURAL. THE MOTION IS
THE PASTOR APPROPRIATIONS BURKE
HI BURKE I WENT. WHEN I GREAT.
GREAT I GRAYSON GRAYSON HI
LEVINE LEVINE HI MAYES RIGHT
MAYES AYE MULLIN. MULLIN ABSENT
PETRIE-NORRIS PETRIE-NORRIS HI
CORK I WORK HI THREE OF US THE
GENERAL SIZE THEY ARE TO I
THERE ARE TWO THE BILL HAS TEN
VOTES THAT BILL IS OUT
CONGRATULATIONS. UP FOR TESTING
ONLY FIVE ITEM AB NINETY.
MISTER GIBSON WOULD YOU LIKE
COME UP FOR I DON'T KNOW HOW
WE'RE DOING.
DO GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO-
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
NINETY SIX. WHICH ASSEMBLY
SEEKS TO EXTEND THE SUNSET TO
CONTINUE- TO ENSURE THAT
PLEDGERS OF COLLATERAL TOWARDS
A PAWNSHOP LOAN CONTINUES. TO
BE TREATED FAIRLY. WHEN SEEKING
TO REQUIRE THEIR SEIZE
COLLATERAL FROM A DEEP FROM
I'M- FOLLOWING A DEFAULT. SO A
LITTLE BACKGROUND IN THE
PROCESS OF GETTING A LOAN FROM
A PAWN SHOP A BROKER PROVIDES
COLLATERAL. THAT MAY BE SEIZED
BY A PAWN SHOP IF THEY'RE BROKE
IF THE BORROWER DEFAULTS ON THE
PAYMENT OF PAYING BACK THE
LOAN. IF THIS SUNSET IS NOT
EXTENDED WHEN A CONSUMER
DEFAULTS AND SEEKS TO REQUIRE
THEIR FOR THEIR SEIZE
COLLATERAL THEY MUST PAY A
SALES TAX ON THE ITEM THEY-
HAVE ALREADY ACQUIRED EVEN
THOUGH THEY HAVE ALREADY PAID
THE INITIAL SALES TAX ON THAT
PURCHASE. MY BILL AB TWO NINETY
SIX SIMPLY SIX TWO EXTENDS THE
SUNSET UNTIL JANUARY ONE TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY SEVEN THEREFORE
LET'S GIVE ME THEREBY
PROTECTING THE CONSUMER FROM
PAYING. SALES TAX TWICE OWN
ITEM. HERE WITH ME TO PROVIDE
SUPPORTING TESTIMONY. LET ME
PAUSE IT WOULD HAVE BEEN BUILT
TO PLEASE SEE. AND WE NOTED MR
BILL TO PLEASE SEE- PASSED AWAY.
SO I'M CARE IN THIS BILL IN
HONOR OF MR BILL TO PLACING WE
HAVE A REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA PONDERED BROKERS
ASSOCIATION WHO WOULD PROVIDE
TESTIMONY I IN SUPPORT OF. TWO
NINETY SIX. WE ALL MISS BILL-
MODERATOR WE PLEASE CONNECT US
WITH UP ORDER TO RICO I BELIEVE
THAT'S OUR- INITIAL AGENCY
SUPPORT. AND ALBERTA THREE CODE
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR THANK YOU IN YOUR COOLEY
STEP THROUGH THE KNOWLEDGE OF
THE WORK ON THE BELT. I WANT TO
TAKE TELL MISTER GIBSON OF
COURSE FOR ALTERING THE BILL
THIS IS A PORTAL TO
REQUIREMENTS TO CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC ASSOCIATION CONSIDER
BETTER MYSELF YOU KNOW WE'RE
TRYING TO ELIMINATE THE DOUBLE
TAXATION ON THESE ON THIS
PROPERTY. I WILL SUGGEST RIDER
ON THE CALL IS AVAILABLE FOR
ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS TO
SETTLE WITH CAPITALIST
LEADERSHIP AS WELL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH RESPECT AS FROM LEVEL
TO PROTECT THAT THEN YOUR STAND
THANK YOU MANAGER. THANK YOU OF
THE MODERATOR NOW OPEN THEM-
MAINLY FOR ANY. ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT TESTIMONY. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR FOR COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO NINETY SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. THE
COMMAND AGAIN. ONE SEVEN ZERO.
AND MADAM CHAIR I SHOW NO
COMMENT AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
SO DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
THE VIDEO ROOM. SEEING NINE ANY
OF THE CHAMBERS SAYING NINE-
MODERATOR CAN YOU SEE IF THERE
IS ANYONE ON THE LINE AND
OPPOSITION. FOUR COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION TO A. B. TWO NINETY
SIX WE'VE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
THAT COMMAND AGAIN AS ONE AND.
ZERO AND MADAM CHAIR I SHOW NO
COMMENT AT THIS TIME. READ ANY
OPPOSITION IN THE VIDEO ROOM
FIFTEEN NINE NINE IN THE NINE
IN THE CHAMBERS AND MISTER
GIBSON WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
OUR ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. C. O. MR
PARK- IN HONOR OF BUILDER
PLESSY I'D CERTAINLY LIKE TO BE
A CO AUTHOR. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF THE HONOR TO HAVE YOU
ADDED TO THE BILL THANKS YOU.
THANK YOU DOCTOR CARTER I WITH
THAT MISTER GIBSON WOULD YOU
LIKE TO COOK- SORRY MR GRAYSON-
OKAY MISS GRAYSON AS WELL THANK
ALL RIGHT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR I BOTH APPROPRIATE TIME
THANK YOU SO MUCH- THANK YOU
MISTER GIPSON REPRESENTATION.
ALL RIGHT. DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
BUSINESS SO THAT. ASSEMBLY
RUMEN TAX INSURANCE.